okay uh
don't panic what do we know pam just
don't panic no don't stop saying panic
you're panicking you have something on
your back
what is that do you have any on you no
no wait why don't you have any on you
day two of the movie channing tatum
walks into this jungle area we have him
take his clothes off and we
covered his back and butt in leeches and
this is day two walking to set with a
bunch of leeches
super glued to my butt
[Music]
and not having met everybody and just
kind of being like okay this is gonna be
uh i'm gonna be butt naked my name's
chan today uh this is just what it is
flip it like a [ __ ]
on me that's something i feel so many oh
holy mother of god why are you are you
praying and then not only that but to
have sandra bullock have like a two-page
monologue with uh a certain part of my
body he was completely naked with a sock
protecting the front area you have to
really like the person and feel safe
with them i need to check your front
okay there was no weirdness like he
would think that there would be
awareness but because he was so chill
about it he dropped everything and i
spoke to it
there is room for leeches there is
available terrain but they have not
explored this beige runway
i'll do that again it's a hell of a day
too let me just say that
[Music]
[Music]